betty white's former assistant pays
tribute to the late actress on what
would have been her 100th birthday you
can't get much better than that kirsten
mikolas betty's longtime assistant
posted this snap of the golden girls
star to betty's official facebook page
monday that's the hollywood legend
posing in a bright green printed top
with white pants gold and white jewelry
and red lipstick and in the caption
kirsten reveals that the picture was
taken on december 20th just 11 days
before her death on new year's eve
kirsten writes that the pick is one of
the last taken of betty i'm just going
along for the ride and having a good
time she adds that at 99 years old betty
was quote radiant and beautiful and as
happy as ever thanks to all of you who
are doing kind things today and every
day to make the world a better place i
think my best wish for the holiday would
be for us all to stop just for a second
and
re-look at our fellow creatures we're
all creatures on this planet and if we
can just be a little kinder to each
other on an individual basis the big
problems will take care of themselves
during et's last interview with betty
leading up to her 99th birthday in 2021
she opened up about how she was feeling
leading up to her big day quote i'm
amazed no seriously i'm the luckiest
broad on two feet to be as healthy as i
am and to feel as good as i do
in fact betty was feeling so good she
was planning on celebrating her
milestone 100th birthday with a
once-in-a-lifetime movie event called
betty white a celebration the film which
premiered on monday betty's birthday was
released in 1500 theaters nationwide i
feel so fortunate to have had as great a
career as i've had for as long as i have
in a press release announcing the
project betty said in part quote who
doesn't love a party this one is gonna
be great the film which takes a look at
her long and successful career includes
interviews with betty behind the scenes
clips of her work and some of her
funniest moments over the years oh it
takes a big woman to forgive somebody
calling her a [ __ ]
the film also includes special tributes
from a-listers who love the late icon
like ryan reynolds tina fey lin-manuel
miranda clint eastwood morgan freeman
jay leno carol burnett jimmy kimmel
valerie bertinelli james corden jennifer
love hewitt and many others i think all
of us truly believe that she would just
live forever i feel so sad that i will
never get to laugh with her again or see
her again
but i also feel so
joyful seeing all the things that people
are putting out about her and how much
they
meant to her and how
you know how she kept us laughing
there's also one last message from betty
to the fans recorded on the same day she
took that final pick the film's producer
opened up to e.t about betty's last
sit-down following the news of her death
december 20th she did a
short little video for us it was kind of
a tribute to her fans that are going to
be with her at the event and it's kind
of a shout out to her fans that she did
10 days before she passed away first of
all she looks amazing she loved getting
glammed up as she calls it and her hair
makeup this is striking and beautiful a
beautiful green
top on bright colored and she was
smiling and really she wanted to thank
her fans sincerely from the bottom of
her heart for all the support over the
years betty died just 17 days short of
her 100th birthday celebration according
to the death certificate obtained by e.t
the beloved actress suffered a stroke
six days before her death in a statement
to et her agent jeff witjos explained
quote i was told that betty passed in
her sleep peacefully without pain to me
this is the most important thing and
brings me comfort as her dear friend
anything else is private to betty and
shortly after she died jeff sat down
with e.t to reflect on betty's impactful
legacy she always called herself the
luckiest old brother i'm a luckiest girl
brought on two feet her legacy would be
bringing people together in many ways
because
young people
older people
great all different races
all love to watch betty white
you can sit in front of the television
and watch whatever she did because it
was funny she never
looked at herself too seriously she had
thoughts about what was going on in the
world
but she kept it to herself
and she brought laughter and happiness
and
a lot of love to a lot of people
[Music]